one of my favorite moments when próxima
tells Scarlett wits
he'll die alone as will you she's not
alone in a real real moment of threat
there's two other women they're starting
by each other it's really great to see
that the audiences are embracing really
strong female super heroines that is one
of the biggest cheer moments in the film
he bombay evolve it the way the Russos
were they were gonna try different
things it was a lot of input and we
could we could share how we would
express ourselves what war cries we used
as what condoms we have another one
that's more okay what's that one it's my
father
that means Windham yes I you're funny
and separate them and they just go ah
you get the actors involved and of
course they know their characters better
than anybody they have great input it's
the greatest Wakata forever you've ever
said this could be it you know it became
like sort of Decatur's of the whole city
people walking around saying what kind
of flu
[Music]
josh brolin is bringing a new iconic
villain to life
Thanos is a very complex character what
he's doing from his point of view is a
very positive thing
he's basically an eco-terrorist and he
wants to eliminate 50% of the universe
to save the other 50%
[Music]
we wanted to tell a story about a
character with a really complex and
empathetic interior life
[Music]
there's not a lot of actors that can
give you both of those things Josh
Brolin brings a reality to the character
he is wearing that mocap suit he's
wearing the motion capture cameras the
performance is coming through not only
in his gestures in his face but in his
eyes there's about 2,900 visual effects
shots in the movie we wanted to make it
as photographic as possible
and I think that that's the most
important part
you
you